uh so
we are
welcome back everybody
[Music]
and
we are
going to continue our discussion of um
computability theory
turing machines
and uh how to prove things undecidable
um
which is what we've been doing um so we
talked about this more advanced method
of proving things undecidable last
lecture called the computation history
method
which comes up in all sorts of
proofs of undecidability and usually
more uh
complex ones
such as for example the proof of
hilbert's tenth problem um
that i mentioned whether you want to if
you want to test
whether a polynomial has a solution
in integers
um
it's a reduction from atm just like
we've been doing all along those are the
all of those proofs are pretty much
reduction from something undecidable
this reduction from
you know from atm is a good as good a
starting point as any
and in um
and it uses the computation history
method so what the end of doing is given
a turing machine and an input you
construct a polynomial
that has several variables
and where
the
in order to get a an integer root an
integer solution of that polynomial um
one of the variables is going to have to
be assigned to some kind of encoding of
a computation history
of the turing machine of that of m on w
it's going to be some one of those
variables is going to be a computation
history
um an integer
which represents the computation history
for m on w um
and
uh the other variables are there to help
you kind of decode that
so that the polynomial can actually
check
and make a solution it becomes a
solution if that actually is a
legitimate computation history of m w so
it really uses the very same method that
we've been using all along but it's uh
it's just a lot it's
it's pretty hairy to construct that
polynomial and do the check
in the way that you need to do
so for the post correspondence problem
which we introduced last time it's
doing the check is relatively simple um
you know that the uh
the match is the is the computation
history and you know following the rules
of the match um is fairly simple to
construct that
uh post-correspondence problem instance
we talked about linearly down to
automata
you know we of course we define
configurations and and computation
histories along the way and proved some
certain problem other problems are
undecidable as well using the same
method
okay um
so today uh we're gonna shift gears
we're gonna in our last lecture on the
computability section of the course
we're going to talk about
something called the recursion theorem
which basically
gives turing machines the ability to
refer to themselves turing machines in
any program to do self-reference um so
that you can actually get at the code
of the turing machine or the code of the
program that you're writing um
even if that's not a built-in primitive
of the
programming language or the operating
system that you're working with it still
gives you that access
um and also we're gonna if we have time
at the end i'm gonna talk a little bit
about mathematical logic which is sort
of a nice application
of the recursion theorem and it's you
know it's a beautiful subject on its own
and it's something that i can give a
brief introduction to okay so today's
topic
is
um
about
self-reference
self-reproducing machines
and the broader topic called the
recursion theorem
um so let me introduce it with the what
i i would call the self-reproduction
paradox
and that is
suppose you have a factory
like a tesla effect or a car
manufacturing uh factory
um
[Music]
here's a picture
uh
of the factory and it's producing cars
all right so we have a factory that
makes cars
and um
what can we say about
the relative complexity
of the cars
compared with the factory in some
informal sense
um
so i would argue that you
would be reasonable to say
that
the
complexity of the factory is going to
have to be greater
than the complexity of the cars
that it makes
because not only does the factory have
to know how to make the cars so it has
to have all the instructions and
whatever things that go into a car it
has to be included in the you know it's
at least in some kind of
has been
in some sense represented in the factory
but the factory also has to have
other stuff
you know the robots and the machine and
the other manufacturing items uh tools
and so on for making the cars
so the factory has to have all the
complexity of a car incorporated plus
other things as well and on that for
that reason one could imagine that the
factory complexity is more than the
car's complexity
but now suppose you want to have a
factory
that makes factories
sort of imagine here's the picture
um
so or in general a machine that makes
copies of itself
well that seems at first glance
to be
uh impossible
um
because
not only does the factory obviously have
to have all of the instructions for what
a factory is like but it needs to have
all of the compo all of the the the
extra things that it would need to do
the manufacturing
and so for that reason it seems like a
um it's not possible
to have a machine make copies of itself
i mean you would run into the very
same problem
if i asked you to produce
a program and what in your favorite
language um
that prints out itself an exact copy of
the same code
i mean you can always write a program
which is going to print out some string
you know like hello world
that's easy because you just put hello
world into
you know some kind of a variable or some
sort of a um you know a table into the
program and say print that table but if
you want to make a print
if you want the program to print out a
copy of itself
you can't take the whole program and
stick that into a table because
um
you know the the program's gonna have to
be bigger than the table
you know and so you're gonna you're
gonna end up with some something
impossible happening because the program
an entire copy of the program can't fit
inside the program
um you just get uh you know cut the
program inside itself inside itself
inside itself forever um and so you get
we end up with like an infinite program
that way
uh so
if you know you just kind of
naively approach the problem for how to
make a program which is going to print
out a copy of itself
it's not so easy to do um
but hopefully
after today's lecture you will see that
it is possible and in fact how to do it
um
and
not only that is an idle
bit curious bit of curiosity but there
are actually applications for why you
might want to do that
mainly within mathematics um and in uh
computer science theory but there's even
kind of a real world application if you
will in a way too
so we'll get to that at the end
um so it seems as i'm saying impossible
to have a self-reproducing machine but
we know that
in the world there are things that make
copies of themselves
living things
um
so
uh it seems like a paradox no cells can
make copies exactly of themselves all
living things can make copies of
themselves um so how do they manage to
get around this paradox
well in fact
there's no paradox
because it is possible to make a machine
that self-reproduces that makes copies
of itself this has been known for
you know
for many years
probably it goes back to von neumann um
who wrote a famous paper on
self-reproducing machines
okay so self-reproducing machines are in
fact possible
[Music]
so let me give you an example of how you
would make a self-reproducing turing
machine
what do i mean by that
i'm going to i mean a machine i'm going
to call it self
which
ignores its input so on any input
you turn it on
machine grinds around for a while and
halts
with a description of itself on the tape
with the description of self its own
code
sitting on the table so very much like
producing a program
which would
uh print out its own code
that's really what we're doing
um
so for that we're going to first need a
little lemma which is a very simple
lemma but it looks more it looks worse
than it is
um
so uh let me just read it out to you and
then i'll explain what it's saying
because what it's
saying is extremely simple
so there's a computable function i'll
call it q that maps strings to strings
which will take any string w
and produce from w a turing machine
which will print w
okay that's all it does so
as you know if i give you a string w you
could produce a turing machine which
would have w
represented
in the um
states and transitions of the machine
so that if you turn the machine on the
machine will be will output w
i mean if i want you to put if you i
want you to give me a turing machine
that predict prints the string
1101 on the tape you could do that i
hope um
and i'm and if no matter what the string
was instead of one one zero zero or one
you know whatever it's you know
20 zeros and then five ones
you could do that too
and in fact um there's a simple
simple procedure that takes a string
and maps that onto a turing machine
which prints out that string
so that's that's a
computable function
um which basically takes a string and
converts it to something that evaluates
to that string
okay and um
i'm calling it q i don't know if this is
helpful to you or not it's kind of like
it converts the string w to w in quotes
so q stands for quotes
in a way
okay uh so if that's helpful maybe
um
then good um
but anyway p sub w is a turing machine
when you turn it on
it just prints out w and holds
okay and i can find piece of w from w
um
straightforward proof
okay so now i'm going to tell you
no
assuming that we have that
that
computable function q
um
i'm going to tell you how to make this
machine self
um and it's not complicated
um
the turing machine
um
a self is going to have two parts i'll
call a and b
here's a here's a schematic for the
machine
so here's self it's in two parts a and b
and what i mean by a and b it's like two
subroutines
uh self is going to start out running a
and when a is finished it's going to
pass control to b
and then b is going to finish the job
and when it's done you're going to have
the description self sitting here on the
tape
all right
so my what's left is to give you the
code for a and for b
okay um
[Music]
so a
is going to be something
super simple
um
a is going to be that machine
which prints out
b
prints out a description of b
um the one that i described up here
so remember p
sub w is the machine which prints out w
and p sub the description of b is simply
going to machine that has this string p
sub b
stored in its states and transitions you
turn on that machine and it prints out b
and then it's done
so this is a very simple image a is very
simple so here just to
here p sub b
um
is a part of a
and when it's done
b appears on the tape so that's at the
point when a has finished its work
now it's going to pass control to b
so we're not obviously done yet because
what we want is a and b both to be on
the tape not just b because self is a
combination of a and b together
um
so
i have to tell you how b
works to finish the job
um
so you might think
um as a first
you know given what we did for for
getting b on the tape that we'll uh get
a on the tape in the same way by putting
a copy of a inside b
so a copy of b is inside a and a copy of
a is inside b
um
and you know at some conceptual level
that seems like that might do the job
but it's really not that is not a
solution
because the fact that i can put b inside
a
um kind of forbids me from also putting
a inside b because that's going to be
the same kind of circular reasoning of
just putting a machine inside itself you
just can't do that because you're going
to end up with an infinitely big machine
that way
you know in fact if i'm putting b inside
a
a copy of b
in terms of its description inside a a
is really going to be much bigger than b
because it has all of b with inside it
plus other stuff
you know the states and transitions for
printing that
uh b out
so i can't have a b much bigger than b
and then b also much bigger than a so
something this is this is no good
we're going to have to do something else
so how is b now going to get a hold of a
um
and the uh
uh
the trick for doing that
without having a copy of a inside b
which we're not gonna which doesn't work
that's not going to that's not going to
be a good solution instead of the way
that b is going to get a it's going to
figure out what it's going to figure out
what a is
and how is it going to figure out what a
is
because if you remember
um
b can look and now look it can look at
the tape it sees some string there which
happens to be a description of itself
but it doesn't care it sees some string
on the tape
a is the machine that prints out that
string
a
is q
of this string
so b is simply going to compute q of
whatever it's whatever it sees on the
tape
that is a
okay so it's i don't know if you can
read this kind of small here
it's going to compute a from b sitting
on the tape so here is the instructions
for b it's going to compute q of the
tape contents which happens to be
the description of b but that's
irrelevant to b
b just sees some string on the tape it
computes q of that and that is the that
is a
because a is the machine which prints
out that string
then it's going to combine
a with b
doing whatever you know slight
interfacing that needs to happen i'm not
going to get into those details
to convert those two pieces into one
machine
which is the machine self
and then it's going to print out with
self on the tape as i'm going to
indicate over here
okay
so that's how
a turing machine
can print out a copy of its own
description
and leave it on the tape
so
and what's nice about this is nothing
specific about turing machines this is a
general
procedure
that allows any programming language
to print out a copy of its own code you
can even carry this out in english
as i'm going to do in the next slide
um
so here's a good question here there are
many possible turing machines that can
print out b
um that's right how do i know how do i
get the the particular one
what i have in mind that's that's a
little bit of a subtle question but but
that but it's a good question
um
i have in mind the the particular turing
machine that prints out b which is the
one that q produces
remember so we you have to refer back to
this lemma
this lemma produces a particular machine
that prints out b
from
from b
and that's the one that i'm going to use
for a and that's the one that b is going
to be able to obtain by running the q
algorithm
to figure out what a is so you have to
make sure you're being consistent it's a
little bit of a detail but but it's a
good question um
and why doesn't this create a circular
argument too well there is no certain so
that was another question i'm seeing
here on the on the tape well there's
there's no longer anything see b
does not have to have a stored within it
it figures out a
so in a sense you're going to write the
program the code for b first
b is just a simple program here it is
there's nothing circular about it says b
is a simple the code for b is take a
look at the tape compute q of
that um combine the result with whatever
was sitting on the tape from before and
print it out
i mean that's a piece of code which you
can just write i mean this will become
more clear hopefully
in our next slide where we talk about
the english implementation
but just just i don't want to rush to
that
so you know you could figure out b
without even knowing what a is b stands
alone
but then
you know because b is just a piece of
code that runs q
based on what it's what it sees on the
tape a
now you need to know what b is in order
to obtain a
because a has the code for b embedded
within a
as a string
so first you produce b
then you can figure out then you can
obtain a there's nothing circular in
this argument i don't know if that's
helpful to you but
you may need to mull it over or maybe
it'll be helpful from the next slide so
let's go there now
okay so as i'm saying you can implement
this in any language in particular you
can implement it in english
okay so let's just shift gears let's
talk about writing down english
instructions
and then i'll show um you know what
happens if you carry out those
instructions so
let's
start simple how about the sentence
hello write hello world
so you know um an obedient person
reading those instructions um would then
write hello world
um on their paper or or wherever
um
okay
fine you get the i hopefully you get you
get the idea um
uh so now what i'd like here's an
here is a
um
another
sentence
another instruction write the sentence
um
and
the uh
the reader uh the obedient reader would
then
okay write the sentence
this is the kind of thing i'm looking
for
here is a sentence which instructs
the reader to make an exact copy
but i don't like this one
even though it does in a sense what i'm
looking for
because
um it it kind of cheats
when it the when it has this
this refers to the entire sentence
itself
it's using
kind of implicitly here
a construct which a turing machine does
not have
the turing machine does not have
a way of accessing its own code
um
and in fact
really what the point of this uh whole
uh theorem that we're going to present
is that you don't need to have this
self-reference as a primitive
you can get that effectively
uh using um
the
procedure that i'm describing which will
give you the same effect so you don't
need it as a primitive you can you can
design some
software basically which will give you
the same effect
um
so let me show you how to do that in
english
so let's do uh uh
let's look at a slightly more oops so
cheating so turing machines don't have
the self-reference primitive so let's
look at another sentence here
write the following twice
the second time in quotes
and then hello world
so what do we get if we follow those
that instruction
um
well you get
hello world and then hello world again
now in quotes
okay
hopefully not too bad
but now i'm one step away for doing the
implementation of the self-reproducing
algorithm
in english
write the following twice the second
time in
quotes and then in quotes the same text
now following those instructions you get
well
write the following twice the second
time in quotes so that comes out here
and the second time you put it in quotes
just like you did with the hello world
but that's exactly
what
um
here the
the output is exactly what the input was
and
there's you know even though there is a
part of the
sentence here which refers to a
different part
so here the the the first part is
referring to the second part
never do i have to have the sense
referring to its entirety
you know uh
there's no part of the sentence here
that's pointing at the entire sentence
um
and so uh this here
manages to get the effect that i'm
looking for where the output is equal to
the the code um but doesn't have the
avoids having the self-reference
is in so it's one thing is referring to
something else but not referring back to
itself
okay um
so uh let me just see here
so here is sort of i'm sort of i'm gonna
have a
check in on this uh in a minute so i'm
gonna try to contrast what's happening
here with what's happening in that
turing machine itself that i had from
the previous slide
okay so a bunch of mulders over and i'm
going to give you a check in to see
this is a little bit of a challenging
check-in um but let's see if you can uh
figure weight your way through it
okay and basically it says so that
really what we're doing here is called
the recursion theorem as you'll see
we'll actually present the recursion
theorem formally on the next slide
um
but
here
in both of these cases we we kind of
have a template part and an action part
both in both cases we have there are two
parts to the instructions the template
and the action
okay so
i'm going to leave it to you to try to
imagine
which of those which is which
in each of these two examples
um
and then i'm going to ask you to pick um
in the turing machine which is the
action which is a template
and in the sentence which is the action
and which is the template the action is
the part that uh where there's some
interesting
sort of
stuff instructional stuff happening that
you have to carry out the template is
really basically just text
or just code just just uh just a string
okay so
let me uh pull up that poll
[Music]
see what you think
because i'm asking you now to to
indicate where is the action part in
both of those cases
what is the upper phrase and lower
phrase i mean of the sentence here so
write the following twice this is the
upper phrase and the part in quotations
is the lower phrase sorry
okay almost done here
five seconds
a few of you have not answered yet
answer it
one second to go
okay here we go
ending polling
so the uh the majority here is correct
um
uh
you know in i would say in the um
english sentence here
uh the action part is the first part
that's where you actually have
being directed to do something
the second half of the sentence the
lower part of the sentence is just a
template
written you know this is just some
string here there's no action really
being directed it happens to be the same
as the top but this could have been just
hello world this could have been
anything
and then the upper part acts on that so
the upper part is the action part so
it's the upper phrase that's the
relevant part now in the turing machine
it's kind of the uh in a sense it's the
other way around
the first part is really just the
template this the second part b
is is where you're doing some actually
work on the template um you're taking
that that uh
basically text which could be anything a
could be anything and your um
uh uh figure take looking at that
template and reconstructing what a was
from the from that uh string that
appears on the tape so b is actually one
the one that's doing the work so it's b
and the upper phrase that's part c is
correct
okay
um so let us uh
continue then um
[Music]
uh
oh
i want to mention here problem six on
the pset um
so you know your job really is to
implement this in
you know if you have a programming
language and you lot that you like you
can you you can it could be
python or whatever your favorite java
whatever you like you can implement this
if you don't know any programming
languages then just make up some sort of
pseudo programming language and
implement it there
let me point out that
um getting the quoting right
um
uh
it is a bit of a pain
um
because you have to kind of escape the
quotes and so on
i'm not going to be fussy about that so
you can still get full credit even if
you don't get the quoting part quite
correct do your best
um i think it's an interesting problem
uh to try to solve and if you you know
if you struggle with it for a while um
you know
you know it's slippery it's the kind of
thing you have to you know
uh you can easily spend a couple of
hours on this problem uh
because it's uh it's it's it's a bit
tricky to manage to make a program which
prints itself out
which is what the task of problem six is
on this on the pset but don't fuss about
too much on the quoting if that's the
only thing that's hanging you up try to
get the main structure of it which is
fairly simple actually um
and if you can't get the quoting part to
work you know i'll ask the graders not
to uh
penalize you for that part
um
uh
okay
uh
let's let let's then look at the sort of
the more formal version of what we've
just done and really kind of also taking
it to the next level
because being able to print out a copy
of yourself is um
is kind of a curiosity in a way
but you know the recursion theorem says
not only can you make a machine which
prints out a copy of itself but you can
actually make a machine which can obtain
a copy of itself and then do some
computation on that copy of itself that
on the on its own description which
actually turns out to be a useful thing
to do
uh once you have access to your own
description as we'll see from some
examples then you can do some perhaps
some interesting things with that
okay um
so basically what what what the
recursion theorem is a kind of a
compiler
it allows you to
have a new primitive when you're writing
turing machines which is compute your
own description
and the recursion theorem will implement
that for you
okay
so the technical form of the um
recursion theorem is going to look a
little bit um
counterintuitive perhaps uh let me put
it out there
if you if you struggle with a little bit
with the slide
don't sweat it the main thing to
remember and we'll see from examples is
that you can compute your own
description uh in a turing machine and
that's going to be allowed as code um
okay so what the way we're going to do
this is
uh
the what the recursion theorem does for
you is it says
um you can write
a piece of code
here let's call it piece of turing
machine code uh algorithm algorithmic
code called t
and t is going to get transformed into a
new machine r
and r is going to get provided
a copy of the program itself which is
just a description of r for free
but otherwise it's going to act exactly
like t so r is going to act exactly like
t except r is going to have provided
a copy of r
and that's what the theorem uh
shows you how to implement
so let me let me just see so for any
machine t there is a machine r
which for any w which is going to be the
input to
the input for r
uh r on w operates the same as t on the
input with w where it's given where it's
given r
so r is going to be
getting access to r without um it's
going to be configuring
obtaining r by by calculating it
maybe it'll be clear from the from the
proof uh i always struggle with how to
explain this clearly
so now the proof of this is going to be
very much like the proof uh from two
slides back uh except there's going to
be three parts
there's the the part t that you're going
to provide
and the t is going to be the turing
machine code that says get your own
description
um and you don't have to worry about how
that happens
uh
the compiler is going to add on the a
and b parts which is going to get the
whole description of the whole thing
which is r
and feed it into t
as if t
you know uh t had it as an input
so it's t is going to be allowed to get
its own description now and operate on
now opera it does its thing you know on
the input w
um
so the way it's going to work so t is
given
uh
a is going to be as before
the description of b now with t
so when a i when a is done
it's going to
produce bt sitting on the tape next to
the w
um
b is going to now figure out what a was
from the bt sitting on the tape
okay
and then it's going to combine that to
get abt which is r
and after that it passes control to t
um with
with w and now r sitting on the tape and
now t the
t is going to have its own description
but don't forget now t has been modified
to be r so it's not that t is going to
get t on the tape it's going to for this
to make sense this is this is going to
be now the new machine r and r is
getting is appears on the tape and now
the code that you provided t is going to
get is going to be now going to get to
operate on that
okay
if you didn't get that i'm not so
i'm not
uh worried um the main thing is that you
can use compute your own description
when you're describing turing machines
that's what this uh thing is uh telling
you
um
i think it'll be
oh there's a check in here
um
yeah so i don't know
let's let's do this one kind of quickly
here
can we use the recursion theorem to
design a
machine t
which instead of producing its own
description
um
um
recognizer recognizes accepts only only
its own description as an input
so the the language of this machine is
going to be simply the one string the
description of t
so can we make it a machine t which
does this no i and now i'm looking at
this checking
this t here is confusing with that t
it's not the same t
that's bad
um i should call it m
design a machine m where l of m is the
description of m
um
and can we use the recursion theorem to
do that
you know what i would ask you to do is
think about it in this context
you can
use
compute your own description when you're
writing the code for this machine
if you could do that could you make a
machine which just accepts strings which
happen to be their own description this
is supposed to be easy but
i think it ended up being a little bit
more complicated than i wanted
um
[Music]
okay launch polling
make your best guess
i think you will kind of see i was kind
of leading you leading you
leading you uh along the path here
yes so uh
i think you're pretty much all are
getting it maybe a few of you are uh
um
[Music]
unsure
um but anyway
let's just wrap this one up quickly uh
so that we can move on i think you're
pretty much so five seconds
i'm going to end it
so the correct answer is yes as i was
hinting at so let's uh i think maybe
this example would have been better
after the next example and then we're
going to have a break um
so here is a new proof that atm is
undecidable
but now using the recursion theorem
and this is going to give you a nice
example of how we use the recursion
theorem
in action
okay so remember
we spent
you know half a lecture
or more
with a proof by diagonalization as our
first example of an undecidable problem
atm we you know subsequently showed
other things undecidable by re
uh by reduction but for the first very
first example we use that
diagonalization
um now i'm going to give you a new proof
okay so proof by contradiction assume we
have a turing machine that decides h
that decides atm it starts the same way
that the diagonalization proof went
but now i'm going to make a new a
machine
called r
so this is going to be diff this is
different from the earlier perf
r says on input w
i get my own description use the
recursion theorem that's the way these
things always start
now
i'm going to use h
now that i know my just my own
description
i'm going to feed
i can ask h
i can feed rw w was the input here i can
feed rw into h
to determine whether r accepts w that's
what h does
h will tell solving atm
h will tell
um
this tell this machine whether r accepts
w
r is the machine we're writing however
that is the machine that that is the
machine where we're currently uh that's
currently running
so h
uh r now uses h
and it knows what it's supposed to do
h is going to say well you're going to
accept w or you're not going to accept w
that's what h is assumed to be able to
do
but then what a what is r going to do
after that
r is going to do the opposite of what h
says it's going to do
so if r
h says r accepts w
then r is going to reject w
um
if
h says r
doesn't accept w it you know rejects it
by looping or whole thing doesn't matter
h just says it rejects
then uh r
it's
just
you know um it's just going to accept
so whatever h says r is going to show
that h is wrong so that's a
contradiction
it says that h cannot be
um deciding atm
so you know if you
step back and think about what this is
here that's that whole diagonalization
proof you know in in in one line
basically we've done that proof uh in a
different way though there is some
similarity here i don't want to say this
we've totally reinvented things and done
it totally differently but it's kind of
in some ways sort of gets at the essence
of the diagonalization in a certain
sense um but anyway it gives you kind of
a new very short proof that atm is
undecidable so i think that's kind of a
cool thing um so why don't we um
uh
take our little coffee break here and
you can feel free to ask questions
during the break
um i will start my timer going
and this will be back continuing lecture
in five minutes
okay so questions so we're getting some
questions on
when i said we don't have to worry about
the quotes um when we're making the
uh
solving uh problem six on the pset uh
somebody says can we just say print abc
instead of uh
print quote abc and it'll print abc yes
you can don't worry about the quotes if
you know
uh i think it's kind of
you'll see a challenge if you want to
try to make get the quotes to work but
it's also kind of a pain so um yeah you
can just kind of ignore the quotes and
i'll ask the graders to to mark that to
mark that for marks there so don't uh
that that's any reasonable
interpretation
will as long as you get the rest of the
concept right we'll be fine
um
let's see uh
somebody is asking in the recursion
theorem why doesn't t get the
description of t instead of the
description of r
because
we're producing the machine that's
running is r
back uh back in the previous uh slide
two slides ago
so if i if r got t it would not be
getting its own description be getting
the description of some other machine so
you need to think about what what we
actually need to have happen here in the
proof of the recursion theorem but it
needs to have r not t um
uh let's just see if i can
why does r do the opposite of what h
says
um
uh
why does r do the opposite of what says
well first of all i'm i'm the one who
gets to design r
so here's the co arc
you know we're assuming we have h i'm
going to design r
to do uh anything i want to satisfy the
proof
and r here is
designed to do the the um
[Music]
the opposite of h
so i'm asking r i'm programming r
to find out what it's what h predicts it
will do and then do the opposite you
know you know i maybe the situation is
sort of uh like this suppose um somebody
says uh
um you know i have a crystal ball
which is going to be like the role of
age he said oh really that's that's kind
of cool um i don't believe you but uh it
still sounds interesting um
and the person says yeah i can see the
future um
uh i you know i know what you're going
to do in five minutes um
uh and in fact i i i can see
that in five minutes you're gonna say
uh hello
and you can say well you know well i'm
you can think to yourself well this
person is nuts i'm not going to
do that i'm just not going to say hello
and then you know the
the genie there with the with the
crystal ball you know waits five minutes
and you don't say hello and then you've
proven that the crystal ball doesn't
work
it's very similar
um
okay uh
okay i'm not going to explain how we can
do the combining itself that's just it's
you know it i'm i just want to explain
at a high level uh
that's just going to be messy so
because i said we're somehow going to
combine and self
let me leave that as a conceptual level
um
okay how does this idea work for turing
machines
i don't really understand that question
how does this work idea work for turing
machines are decidable you'll have to
resend that because i don't understand
the question
um
can i explain use your own description
so when i when you write code that says
get your own description
um
after that code executes
the turing machine has
a appears on the tape like magic
um the description of
its own code
you say sitting next to the input to the
machine if because the machine may have
an is separate input from that
so the machine just magically gets its
own code and the the proof of the
recursion theorem implements that
so it's not magic after all
um
uh
i still don't understand the question
um
so for problem six is it enough to
attach code if you're yeah you can
attach code for problem set six problem
six um
and um
that's that's good enough and or if you
can explain it's also good well you like
usual do we worry about tabs and new
lines no
um
[Music]
uh
okay we're gonna have to defer the rest
of the questions don't forget we have a
zillion questions here which i didn't
get to uh
okay last last one here why does
programming artist do the opposite of h
is that a contradiction
well h is predicting that r accepts but
r doesn't accept so h is wrong
we're a little short on time let me skip
this one
uh you can look at this on your own
i mean this is proving sort of the cool
fact
that if you have a i'll just say a high
level if you have a
a program transformation
so if i have some method of transforming
one program to another program but it's
done by algorithm so an algorithmic way
that transforms one program to another
program there's always going to be some
program whose behavior is unchanged by
the transformation
that's called the fixed point theorem um
so there's some program whose behavior
doesn't change no matter how you try to
transform programs easy proof using the
recursion theorem um
you know you can
look at the slide
offline separately
you know if you'd like to see how that
goes it's pretty simple um
uh
here's another exercise uh from of the
recursion theorem um
um
so if i have a um
uh
uh
uh
let's say a minute
a turing machine is minimal
if um its description
is the shortest
among all turing machines
which behave the way it does which were
equivalent to it
um
you know
you know
when i was an undergraduate we had to uh
you know we had i took a programming
class
and some of us sort of enjoyed writing
short programs to uh
uh to carry out the exercises
um
you know probably these days that's
forbidden because it just encourages bad
programming style but anyway
um and
so
uh you know you kind of won if you found
the shortest solution for a given
programming exercise you know it was
heap sword i remember it was one of the
ones that we had to do
um
so
um
uh
you know this is sort of similar you
know you might you might imagine if
people try to find the shortest possible
universal turing machine
so shortest in our in our sense is in
terms of whatever encoding method we
have in mind
a machine is minimal if there is no
shorter program which does exactly has
which is equivalent using our descript
using our encoding uh system whatever it
is okay
so anything m is minimal if anything
that's
that has a shorter description has a
different language
um
okay so let's look at the uh collection
um of all
descriptions of minimal turing machines
and i'm going to prove that that
language is unrecognizable
i'm going to do it using the recursion
theorem it's kind of a cool exercise um
and you can actually use it to prove
something more powerful but but let's
focus on this
this theorem for for now
um
so
assume we have and it's also a little
nice exercise about enumerators um i
don't know how comfortable you ever got
with the numerators but uh let's i'm
trying to prove this language here is
not recognizable and so remember
enumerators
you can enumerate exactly all the
recognizable languages so i'm going to
assume i have an enumerator for this
language which just prints out all of
the
um
minimal touring machines so i have in
some enumerator it's a program that
prints out
the descriptions of all of the minimal
the shortest possible turing machines
and now i'm going to get a contradiction
so
we're going to take build this turing
machine r which gets its own description
and then it's going to start the
enumerator
um
until
so the it's not looking at the strings
that the numerator produces so this
enumerator is producing these minimal
touring machines one after the next
chunk chunk
chunk all these minimal touring machines
are coming out
and you keep looking at those until you
find one of them which is bigger than
yourself
and how do you know how big you are
yourself
from the description you're given by the
recursion there
so you can't keep up printing out these
uh turing machines until you find one
that's bigger than yourself
and then what do you do with that you
simulate that
so
um
now so
so what well the point is is that you're
going to be smaller
than that machine that you're simulating
because you waited to find a machine
that the enumerator produced which is
bigger than you
so you're going to assume you're going
to be simulating that machine that's
bigger than you
and so you're going to be doing exactly
what that machine does on every input
because you're always going to be
simulating that same machine on every
input
and so you're going to be equivalent to
that bigger machine
but that bigger machine
is supposed to be minimum because e is
producing it
but here you are exhibiting a machine
that's smaller than that um that's
allegedly minimal machine it couldn't be
minimal that's the contradiction
so
the language of r this machine i just
produced equals the language of b
because rs ends up simulating b
um
but r is smaller than b because
r waited until it found a bigger machine
that's bigger than it so b couldn't be
minimal
but b was one of the machines that the
enumerator produced that's a
contradiction
um
so let me uh
do a checking on this i i expect this is
going to cause some of you heartburn but
but let's let's do the best you can
um
uh
suppose i have this collection of
minimal touring machines and i take some
infinite subset of that
so and now i'm not demanding that i have
all of the minimal touring machines i
just have infinitely many minimal
touring machines
is it possible that subset whatever it
is
could be touring recognizable
now think about that
now you can you can have
languages which are not touring
recognizable that have
infinite touring recognizable subsets
could that be for this language
and maybe i'll give you um
it will be helpful to you to understand
and perhaps apply
the methodology that i gave you in this
proof here
and that might be helpful to you
but i can see
you know this is not uh this one is is a
bit of a struggle
okay let's end it
okay um
two seconds
just pick something
all right so the majority has the uh
correct answer here
um
um
so in fact
this proof
uh
would still work
if uh the enumerator was enumerating an
infinite subset
of minimal turing machines
because all you need is to wait until
one that's bigger than your appears
and that's you know
all that r needs to do is wait until one
that's bigger than r appears which will
certainly happen eventually if the
subset is infinite
and then r simulates that that simulates
that bigger machine and acts the same
way
thereby proving it could not be minimal
um
so it's exactly the same proof shows
that the answer here is no
um and it's a kind of a curiosity it's
not necessarily that easy to construct
languages
which not only are they not recognizable
but they have no recognizable subsets
infinite subsets obviously a finite
subset is going to be recognizable
because it would be decidable
as well
okay so let's anyway let's move on
some other applications
so first
uh a real world application
um
uh
somebody's asking for an example
of a language
uh of a recognizable uh subset
of a non-recognizable
language so starting out with something
which is not recognizable
and
um
um
uh
what can we come up with a quick
um
so
here's
um i don't know if this will help you so
i the question is can i give an example
of a non-recognizable language that has
a recognizable subset
uh so
i didn't prepare this but
let me see if this is uh helps helps you
know so let's take atm complement we
already showed that atm complement is
not recognizable
right so these are
the the sets of
pairs m and w where m does not accept w
okay
um
so
if i focus only on those m's
which are finite automata
which are a subclass of turing machines
then i can get the answer for those m's
so for the infinitely many cases where
the turing machine never writes on its
tape
i can it's even becomes decidable
okay so i don't know if that's helpful
um
but uh you can definitely find
cases where there are
undecidable languages that have
decidable subsets unrecognizable
languages that have recognizable
infinite subsets um but there's one
example where it's not true in the
previous slide
um
okay a lot of questions coming up here
yes
i'm seeing some other proposals here
if you take atm
complement and you union it with
just any all strings of ones just one
star assuming that one star
just strings the ones they're never
going to code for a turing machine um
that's still going to be unrecognizable
but then you can just throw away all of
those
those just strings of ones and you're
going to get an infinite subset oh wait
a minute
still unrecognizable that's not good
um
oh no yeah
i threw away the wrong stuff you throw
away the um
the descriptions of the turing machines
and you just have the one star strings
left
and so that becomes decidable even
regular
anyway i think i'm not sure i'm helping
you uh let's move on to other
applications so this is kind of a cure
curious application um
that actually is a real world where a
machine might want to get a copy of
itself and then do something perhaps
even
uh nefarious
with that uh with a copy of its own code
and that would be a computer virus
computer viruses up to you know
make copies of themselves
and then propagate them through the
internet or whatever uh media you have
to infect other computers and you know
i'm sure we all know how
you know about computer viruses um well
i mean they need to get copies of
themselves
in order to do that uh
to do the infection
um how do they do that
um
you know many of them operate in a way
where you know in in a
either in a language or or in a system
where they can make reference to their
own code either by looking at the um you
know the uh the the
um
the machine code or whatever uh direct
direct access to their own code there
are languages which allow and systems
which allow for that
but i'm not an expert on computer
viruses i would be shocked if they're
not some other
uh viruses that get access to their own
code by using something um you know in
the in the same s i using basically the
method of the recursion theorem this you
know i haven't done a systematic study
but i'm sure if you can't access to your
own code directly using some operating
system uh mechanism some primitive the
only other way is basically doing the
method that we just described
okay
so another application
um
is
in
a branch of mathematics called
mathematical logic
um
where i imagine that many of you have
heard of the work of girdle from the
earlier part of the 20th century where
they show that um
you can come up it's possible to
demonstrate
that there are true mathematical
statements but which cannot be proven to
be true
um
so proof
uh there might some be something like
maybe even you know questions of
interest to us you know like the p
versus np question which we will some at
some point uh look at in in a few weeks
um actually yeah maybe two or two two
weeks from now um
many unsolved mathematical problems and
you know people's wonder
you know maybe there's just no way to
prove them one way or the other
so um
in the 1930s when girl did his work he
shocked the mathematical community by
showing that there are truth that proof
it does not work for everything there
may be things that are true that you
cannot prove um
uh
you know hilbert in particular you know
from hilbert's 10th problem he was
dismayed by this result uh
because he believed that you know he had
earlier believed that anything that was
true you could prove um
uh so anyway let's let's just see how
let me i'm gonna sketch
how we actually go about doing that um
because we now have a kind of enough
technique to at least give you an idea
of how do you demonstrate that there are
true but unprovable statements and
actually even exhibit one
okay mathematical logic is the
mathematical study of mathematics itself
um
girdle's first incompleteness theorem as
we described is that in any reasonable
formal system of uh mathematical
probability there are going to be some
true statements that are not provable
um
and in order to sort of get this
sketch of the proof i shouldn't say
proof here we're gonna proof sketch
um
we're gonna basically use two
um properties of formal proof systems um
one is that
kind of the
kind of obvious property that you would
expect all provability systems to have
is that you can only prove true things
so if something is being proven
it's going to be true you can't prove
you can't prove anything false
if you if you can prove false things
your system of proof ability is bad
um
and the other thing is that um
proofs are checkable by machine
so if you write down your
your do your system in a formal way and
you have this formal notion of proofs
which underlies all mathematical
reasoning by the way this is completely
well accepted both of these properties
are accepted by mathematicians then in
principle you can convert any
mathematical proof
into a form that you can check it by
computer it might become much longer but
in principle you can put the proof into
a form where uh um a computer could
check the proof and the way we're going
to use
uh frame that you know in the way we've
been just talking about things is that
the language of all pairs of proof comma
statement being proved
so where the pi is a proof of the
statement fee
um that's a decidable thing so you can
check
by machine
whether pi is a valid proof of fee
your your proof checker
can say yes it's valid no not valid and
that's something you can do by algorithm
okay so those are the two assumptions
that we're going to make about our
system of proofs and that's all we're
going to need
um now the first conclusion which is i
think you know a good sort of little bit
exercise on the on
the kind of thinking we've been doing in
this course
number two checkability implies that the
set of provable statements
is recognizable
why
suppose i give you a um a statement that
has a proof
a provable statement
i'm not saying a true statement
necessarily that's going to be
you know
perhaps a larger class of statements but
the statements that do have proofs
that's a recognizable language
um
because you know if i give you a
statement
your recognizer is going to take that
statement and start looking through all
possible
proofs
it's going to look at string after
string as a candidate proof one after
the next some strings of course most
strings are just going to be junk but
every once in a while a proof is going
to come out that's going to be a valid
uh a string which is a valid proof of
something and then you're going to check
oh let me just see if that's a valid
proof and if it does prove the statement
i have in mind and if it is then i
accept that statement
and i go through statement by you know
is
the input is a
mathematical statement and that's going
to be accepted if the machine by looking
through all possible proofs finds one
and then it accepts that statement so
the collection of all statements that
have a proof that's recognizable
so similarly
if um
you can
if you take statements of the form
m and w
is not in
is in the complement of atm so m doesn't
accept w
if you take all statements of that form
where m doesn't accept so m and m
doesn't accept w or m w is in the
complement of atm
um
some of those statements may have proofs
so in your system some of them may not
have purse
if all of them had proofs
if you can prove every statement of this
form when it's true when it happens to
be true
obviously you can't prove the ones that
are not true but if you can prove all
the true verb statements of this kind
then atm complement would be turing
recognizable
because you can go through
you can just
uh you know for the same reason as above
but we know that that's false
so there must be some statement of this
kind which is
true
but does not have a proof because
otherwise atm complement would be
recognizable
um
okay so we've actually done the first
half
of um
of girdle's uh incompleteness theorem
the second half which we're going to
unfortunately
not have time to finish but let me just
give you the outline
is that we can use the recursion theorem
to give it specific see
what we showed here is that there is
some statement of this form which is
unprovable which is true but unprovable
doesn't exhibit a particular one
now the recursion theorem allows you to
give a particular one um
and
uh the the one it basically implements
girdles the cold so-called girdle
statement or girdle sentence that says
this statement is unprovable
um
and you can frame formalize that
um
uh precisely
and then that statement becomes true but
unprovable
let's let's just say why that is
because if the statement
were false
suppose this statement were false
then well then it would be provable
because the truth the truth says it's
not provable but if the statement were
provable then it had to be true
which would mean it would be unprovable
so the only viable outcome here is that
the statement is unprovable
um
and which is
it's therefore
that
that it's true that it's unprovable so
that this is a true statement but then
it has no proof
and
uh let me not go through it um because
again we're
unfortunately ran short on time but uh
you can implement this um using uh the
recursion theorem to make a to make a
particular machine r
where you cannot prove
um that r does not accept uh say some
string zero
um
so you can find a particular r using the
recursion theorem where it's impossible
to prove that r doesn't accept zero
um
even though by construction r does not
accept zero
uh so it's a little bit slippery there
because you have to understand what we
mean by proof within the formal system
versus versus our external form of
reasoning but
taking us a little bit far afield
uh so for those of you who care um
i hope this little digression was
interesting
as i mentioned at the beginning uh for
those of you don't care you don't have
to worry about it it's not going to be
on the midterm or on the final exam
you're not going to be responsible for
this last you know five minutes or so of
the lecture but i thought it's kind of
an interesting application of the
recursion theorem to a problem outside
of computer science in mathematical
logic
um
okay uh so uh
here's the entire the reasoning here
again i invite you to look at that um on
the slide uh
you know that i posted if you're curious
um
so anyway quick review of today is we
went through the self-reference and the
recursion theorem we gave a few
applications
and we did a sketch of girdle's first
incompleteness theorem in mathematical
logic
okay so that's all i'm going to have for
you today we're out of time
um and
i will um
take any questions
so getting back to the min turing
machine example somebody's asking how do
i know there's a turing machine that's
longer than the machine r that i'm
building
well there are infinitely many machines
in mintm or in the infinite subset of
minty m so eventually one of them is
going to have to be longer than the
machine that i'm machine that i'm
constructing because that's going to
that's a machine of some very specific
size
and so eventually there's going to have
to be one that's bigger that shows up
so this may be a similar question
give
now another similar question is about
how big is r uh and does r the size of r
in that previous thing here uh
i don't know if we want to go through
this but okay let's let's quickly look
at it
this machine r
has a fixed predetermined size
um its size does not depend on
b it depends on e
because it's going to be simulating e
but you know e might be a norm producing
very very long strings eventually it
will
so e is fixed
and then um
you know uh
and then r's size is fixed so eventually
r will find a machine that's bigger than
it is
um
let's let's look at
right
so this is a this is a good question i
was wondering if i would get questions
of this kind this is getting back to the
question in logic here at the end um
uh
yes because you know i said this
statement here is unprovable
but in a sense i proved it because how
do i know it's
it's true
and i'm gonna i gave you um you know an
argument for it and so you have to
differentiate between
uh the reasoning that we're providing
and the formal system that we're
reasoning about
and the formal system that we're
reasoning about is not capable of
proving this but we're outside that
formal system so that we can reason
about the formal system i know it's a
little bit perverse seeming um and
mathematical logic is a little tricky
because it has to deal with those kinds
of issues but um you know this is
arguing within any particular formal
system of provability
um
you know this is going to be true um and
but you know
uh
that's kind of an approximation to our
own thought process uh so it's it's it's
it's still it's slippery i i agree
um
so good question here would girdles
theorem still hold in formal systems
where we don't require that proofs of
statements are decidable so i'm not
saying that the proofs are decidable is
that you can prove
checkable so you can test whether a
proof is a proof
if you can't test whether a proof is a
proof i don't know of any people have
studied that that situation so that's a
little bit
of a trickier
trickier case i'm not sure what to say
about that um
can i give an example of two equivalent
turing machines where one has a shorter
description than the other
how do we define the length of this of
the description
well
we never really precisely defined our
encoding
system
but whatever encoding system you want to
use
is going to have it's going to
you know
represent turing machines as strings
and those strings are going to have a
length and so
it doesn't really matter which encoding
system you're going to use because this
statement is going to be true in any of
them
you know we could go through the
exercise of defining a particular
encoding system it's going to be pretty
tedious to do that but you can just
imagine
writing down the states the
transition function
you know etc etc etc as this big long
string
and that's going to be our encoding
system and then are going to be some
long machines some machines will have
long representations on other machines
that have short representations and you
know if there's going to be some machine
where you're going to introduce you can
introduce a bunch of useless states that
are never accessed so you can
you know expand
you you can kind of add
junk to the description of the machine
which is not going to do anything but
it's just going to make the
description of the machine unnecessarily
long
compared to what with with some other
description which is going to
compute the same thing but will be much
shorter
so you can certainly find
examples of pairs of the machines
pairs of machines that do the same thing
where one is much longer than the other
um
so i will then uh close the session here
and um
i will be uh very shortly on um on the
office hours link um
and uh see some of you there
you